so I always think to myself what if my
sister was ever doing any one of these
things that you got I would just pull it
to the side and say like what are you
doing so the fact that girls don't
actually pull their friends to the side
like you know what I'm trying to say to
you like we had to we had to pull her
onto the podcast because she didn't want
to get on the podcast but she has a
really good point of view and I'm saying
to her literally like no you need to you
need to tell people like what like your
opinion because we need girls that
actually get what we're saying and are
willing to be vocal about it but all
these girls are going to say he's a pick
she's a pick me well I think it says
something about the competition that is
between women as general I mean like if
you look at the globes in general there
are more women on the planet than there
are men so if every man were to get paid
off today I'm sure we've all heard this
talking point many times before if all
men were to get part of today there'd be
a purple woman left over it is a
competition it really is no but if you
want the footballers and if you want the
rappers then what about the normal man
it's not it's not just about the
football it's a mattress though it's a
competition for every man in general in
order to get
like even when you look at all these
girls go look at their Instagram
comments right look at the likes look
even when they're in a relationship
you'll see all these men comment in like
and being simps in the comments right
but end of the day a lot of times you
can just pick one of these guys and and
live your best life they look they
literally in public saying how much they
want you but you don't pick none of
these guys in actual fact you pick
someone that's gonna be be having access
to so many women that he actually can
look at you like actually maybe I don't
I don't need this but all the guys in
the comments in the DMS you guys ignore
them you literally ignore them why well
isn't that a part of the saying that
women want the top 10 percent of men the
men that are earning like maybe six
figures or six foot tall or so on so
forth the ones that look that good on
Instagram look there's one two three
four there's five women in here if only
one of if only one of us in here is that
guy you can't all get them you have some
of you are gonna have to concede
absolutely but I think the point is is
that if there was a man here that was
six foot earning six figures and he
presented himself as such hello awesome
let me just throw that in there because
like what what yeah like yeah but yeah
in the little conversation if we got to
know each other better I do believe that
most women would be wanting to go for
that man rather than the other men
simply because he stands Head and
Shoulders above all other men like I'll
give you another example there could be
um like I've seen it in my personal life
I've got a lot of cousins that are
bodybuilders and they have amazing
bodies they don't get instant
gratification the same way on social
media that one of my cousins he he was
female know he maybe doesn't work out as
much that's instant classification when
she posts a bikini picture why is that
yeah because men just want to bang you
absolutely that's true so women are the
gateway to Sexes but you can't get
excited about a man comment and you're
giving like this is the thing it says
it's mad to me because if you get if you
actually get excited that a man sliding
your DMs or gives you a compliment then
you are you don't actually you've I
don't want to say you're you're low
value
if that's what gets you going then that
that's going to be really hard for you
because you're going to go through life
and then these types of women you're
gonna actually actually if you feel
sorry for these types of women because
you a lot of men can lie to you and this
is how a lot of these women end up
getting damaged because they go through
quite ditzy quite not know what's going
on men say all these things and you've
got to remember there's two types of men
right this there's men that on their
purpose that well there's more than two
types of men but we're gonna talk about
men that on their purpose but and that
want to get out there that actually
being productive that are getting money
that could be six foot that could be all
these things that you think of but for
some reason you believe these men want
to be outside they don't want to be
outside what they want to be they want
to be inside with a good woman but
because you look at the other guys that
do that type of thing you automatically
think these men are going to cheat then
you have the other men look these men
are always going to be in them so always
going to be simple for this but you none
of you women pick these men and when I
say simple I don't mean they're not
going to be good men I just mean they
could give you everything you want
bar the six foot bar some of these other
things they're six figures but they
could be a good man and they would love
you but you disregard them so if only
one of us is that guy let's say that's
me in this room and the rest of them and
what about the rest of the men why don't
they get a shot I think you're
generalizing because it's exciting yeah
yeah I would say he's not because I
think dating app data allows women to be
very much no I think dating app data
allows women to be very honest about
what they like and what they want and
women only swipe right between five on
the high end 20 of the time
and so where men swipe right 50 of the
time
I don't even use dating apps I'll never
use one either and any girl that's been
on a dating app for me is for the
streets oh wow
yeah go ahead listen we okay
you have to remember right no I'm just
interested how many times how many times
you get moved through in a week let's
say you just cut let's go you go London
transport a week how many times do you
think you get moved to a week
just honestly ladies just just throw a
figure once a week once a week
same you so once a week a man moves you
once a week actually it's even less than
probably less I want someone with me
so when you're outside in the public a
man will only approach you once every
single month so that 12 times a year I
can't count I know already your captain
I know you're Captain I understand I'm
going to be honest I'm going to be
honest like if we're gonna do this be
honest like you only get me through once
a week in the public and you catch trade
and you go come on man let's be real
once a day maybe you know I'm trying to
say to you so so so
be honest I don't know okay cool so when
in real life with women right whether or
not to get moved to once a week or once
a day when you go onto social media put
yourself on a dating app you now put
yourself as meat you're not selling
yourself I consider that selling
yourself right so whereas before natural
interactions many will actually have to
come up to you and actually have to have
that bit of you know confidence let me
speak to you that little bit of where
you can smell a man you can see a man
you can pick up all them Rhymes now you
just put yourself and said yo look at me
right and so when you do that it says to
me you cheap yourself so my so not only
can I see you my boys can see you now
automatically right and so for us when
we see a girl that's on dating apps a
lot of my friends are on there and they
just it's for hookups they're just
having sex with girls right and girls
say oh I'm not on there I'm not on there
for that and my friend met there you
know I know someone that got married on
the dating app and that's like the
lottery that's like saying I know
someone that played the lottery and they
want everybody to know someone that
played a lottery one but how many people
played a lottery ever since actually
it's actually just Devil's Advocates the
number one way that people are meeting
up the number one way relationships
starting nowadays is online and that's
why I take that like dating apps like
because a lot of people will discredit
the dating app stats because they'll say
like oh like not everyone uses it for
relationships or for that stuff but like
that's the number one way people are
meeting nowadays I've I've met two
people actually that got married and a
dating app so yeah I'm not saying you're
incorrect I would I would guess a ton of
that is for like I would guess a ton of
that's very casual but but if you're
surveying people on where did you meet
your partner and the number one way is
is dating apps but like I can't where
did you get married to your partner
should be the question like because no
it's the same so it's it's it's the same
so yeah so for me every guy that I know
in dating app is not getting married on
a dating app no no will actually say I
met my girl in actually if you did you
would keep that quiet because I think it
depends on the dating app personally
yeah because there are some people who
pay money to get away from certain
people or dating apps so for example
there's eHarmony where you actually have
to pay a subscription you're paying to
get away from a certain demographic
people by doing that because let's be
available if you're just looking for
casual hip-hop the likelihood is you're
not trying to pay money to go on
eHarmony for casual hip-hop I don't know
like I don't really care either way but
I I just can't like Overlook the stats
that I that I've seen no you know what
I'm saying but for me yeah and okay so
the stats that you're seeing okay cool
yeah
where I'm coming from I can we are we're
not meeting our wives on dating apps and
in actual fact the friends that are on
dating apps are telling me all the fun
and sex they're having on dating apps
right and they have to be having sexual
women that want to be having sex because
you have to understand women are very
empowered now and there's a lot of
feminists and and and
um strong would you consider Instagram a
dating app okay it is a dating app but
you're not on there to date so it's
different so if you meet someone
organically through the comments through
that stuff that's different but when you
actively put yourself on they say swipe
and tap in it's different so let's say I
meet you today and it's going really
well it's going really well you know I'm
talking to you we're speaking for a week
I'm like yo I'm saying to my boy G-Shock
man I've met the girl in my dreams man
like that everything's going well I
can't wait to see her then you know I
mean then you know what it is um the
gaffer he then gets on the app the
following week and all of a sudden she
gets a bit bit colder me because she's
had a better match now but for the last
week I've been thinking you know I've
met my woman I only met my woman because
she hadn't had a better match and that's
what happens in real life she wouldn't
have that many options but because
literally she's a girl and every single
day a new hot match all of a sudden I'm
competing with guys I even you know the
types of guys I'm competing with I don't
even know see I would say that
Instagram's like the same
like I think it's the same I think I
would guess like more people meet on
Instagram than that if you want to do
that I don't think it's organic if
you're looking up a girl's ass pick like
a plan
I think that also somewhat contradicts
the point that you made earlier that you
meet naturally in public but then you
have this instant classification like
how can you say it's a natural on
Instagram
because listen they said there's a big
difference in doing a dating profile and
saying look this is my age sex my
location whatever it is this is their
description there's a big difference
between between that and you having an
Instagram for business for whatever
you're just having a normal what percent
of girls have Instagram for businesses
for me there's a big difference there's
a big difference I'm being honest
because because not my friends wouldn't
just automatically find your Instagram
and start speaking to you when you put
yourself on these apps or in the
algorithms all of a sudden do you know
how many friends exes we see on
Instagram we're like oh oh sorry on um
on on apps yeah and like okay cool the
relationship ended she's in the 30s now
so we know where she's ended up on the
day and we just laugh because we already
know what she's about to go through so
once you end up on the on a date and
that why would you be on a date and up
if if you were really that you don't
find quality women on date
can you find him on Instagram
no I'm not saying you find him on
Instagram but I'm saying on the dating
app I would think that if I was on a
dating app I'll be realistic and I would
know I'm not gonna find my wife on that
and I would tell any guy that's on there
bro like you know yeah fair enough fair
enough but I I feel like it scraps the
same thing no it's not
I I I think Instagram's the same thing I
think all social media is the same thing
I think it's I think the difference is
if
if a man has options he uses a social
media to uh explore his options if a man
doesn't have options he use social media
to find love and that's the difference
when people say oh yeah I use social
media and I found women on my dreams
there's a reason why he's on social
media I didn't and he didn't go to a bar
or a club and find uh the woman that he
wanted I think every boy does dream
about meeting that perfect woman in that
perfect place they might not admit it
but they will say that yeah when I'm
young yeah I want to get a nice wife
getting my nice family there build on my
clan but the last thing we're thinking
about is I want to find my wife on
Tinder that's the last one but you can
find your wife anywhere could be a
Tinder of course a man with options will
not go on social media to find a
relationship yeah
that's the difference a man with options
in a manner that doesn't have options a
man that doesn't have options we'll go
on social media to look for love why
would a woman why would a quality woman
even be on there advertising herself
like oh just pick like the Swap and you
can get him like why would you do that
if he was really that girl every single
day you step into the line as many of
you know I was just banned on Tic Tac
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible